Does China have democracy?
Many people equate democracy with
the direct election of government leaders
and then jump to a conclusion,
just hold your horses, please
think about it. Why do we need democracy?
What are the meanings and values of democracy?
For me, the answer is very simple.
That is for a better life.
So
if every vote is cast for a party that is beholden to vested interest,
if the leaders you elect are just sophisticated,
self serving people who offer only empty rhetoric,
if your democracy doesn't actually help people leave better lives,
then your democracy is nothing more than an empty shell.
Yes, indeed.
China does not have that type of democracy.
China has the real democracy. Cheers.